[Music]
this is queen's freddie mercury on
september 19 1980 and next to him is
lead guitarist brian may
who in july 2021 returned home to find
his kensington london home flooded
sewage
sludge
[Music]
he blamed the basement building that has
been plaguing this area for the past 10
years
[Music]
from 2008 to 2019 7
328 basements were added to homes in
london
basements not just for the rich
but the super rich
all of these dots represent private
underground swimming pools
and cinemas
and wine cellars
click to london's top luxury realtors
sort by price and you'll find underwater
playgrounds and theaters
homes like this 25 million pound one
with two basement levels including a bar
and spa
london's elite
are building underground
layers it's an interesting kind of
conflict between these different very
very wealthy people
or as we said i think in one paper we
say is that conflict between the habs
and the happy arts
and professor roger burrows i'm a
professor of cities in the school of
architecture planning and landscape at
newcastle university
but i'm not an architect nor am i a
planner i'm essentially a sociologist in
the statistician do you remember how
y'all got the idea though was it
literally just you're walking down the
street you see a ton of construction
trucks all the time and you wonder
why is there always construction on this
street and then you say oh i bet they're
making a basement exactly we we were in
we were doing a case study of four or
five different neighborhoods in london
and we were interviewing residents about
what was happening in the neighborhood
we would notice as we were doing this
streets with five or six of these
excavations going on same time with
lorries moving up and down
[Music]
and indeed the people that we're
interviewing really just wanted to talk
about it because they felt that their
neighborhood was being ruined each
borough in london has a planning
commission where people have to submit
renovation plans burroughs and his
co-authors searched every application
and found all the basements and then
mapped them but mostly it's concentrated
around the great parks around hyde park
kensington chelsea
and hammersmith and fulham brian may's
house in kensington had an original half
underground floor suddenly his neighbors
were all building basements of an
entirely different scale a well-off
neighborhood became
extremely well-off transnational elites
were literally burying millions and
millions of dollars in the ground
so this isn't as much of a thing in
america do you have a sense why that is
is it the historic codes in london
you can't really change the outside
appearance of a property you can't fill
the loft though and you can't spend at
the back but because of the freehold
laws you own
all of the land under the property so
you can burrow down a lot of it is also
geological new york
is another kind of world city where you
might expect these things to be
occurring they're happening a little bit
in brooklyn but you're literally trying
to mine out rock the great thing about
london is of course it's clay so it's
very easy to dig down and generate these
spaces
burroughs and his co-authors mapped
standard large and mega basements
and what we call mega basements are
three stories or more
or two stories
but which extend beyond the envelope we
find 118 of those and they're on a
ginormous scale this map shows their
concentration in wealthy neighborhoods
the combination of incredible wealth and
inflexible exteriors led to massive
basement builds wine cellars gyms art
galleries ballrooms panic rooms gun
stores
[Music]
in the late 1800s a ship owner named
charles booth started tracking
inequality in london a gradient that he
mapped from wealth to poverty compiled
through extensive surveys
[Music]
there is now a clear what i would call
basement belt
in london uh and concentrated within
within particular uh neighborhoods in
particular particular street so i think
it is a physical
manifestation of gross wealth
in the mid-2010s london burrows began to
curb permits for multi-level basements
because of resident concerns like those
of queen's brian may
the consequences are more than just
flooding deep digging can cause
structural collapses but basement
construction hasn't stopped completely
gianluca viale was one of the best
italian strikers in the 1980s and 90s
when he moved to london in 1996 his
legend only grew as he moved into
management
he helped lead italy to win the euro
2020 final
in 2020 he appeared in the lower right
corner of a video conference stream
begging the kensington and chelsea
applications committee not to let his
neighbors
expand their basements after he'd lived
through earlier construction the noise
pollutions and the air pollution has
been unbearable i beg you not to give
them permission to do that no one can be
successful unless they make the life of
everyone else around them a nightmare
[Music]
today his neighbor's house is for sale
it's lavish there's also one major
selling point
the planning board has granted
permission
for a basement excavation
[Music]
you